now going green in an effort to cut down
on waste 8 news now reporter Mary Jane
beliesa shares the new way Las Vegas
organizations are tracking their carbon
footprint
every single person has a carbon
footprint and it can add up depending on
the decisions you make like the car you
drive to what food you waste Adam Kramer
CEO of n0 a nevada-based carbon
accounting and management company says
more businesses are adopting sustainable
practices we're not just an accounting
platform we're telling them and giving
them tools on how to reduce it and we're
like we can actually help reduce your
footprint by 30 percent oh and by the
way we can reduce your cost by 35 people
like whoa I can make a decision that
both reduce environmental impact and
cost I'm a yes with millions of visitors
making their way to Las Vegas each year
the Las Vegas Convention and visitors
Authority is taking the lead on going
green Lori Nelson craft senior vice
president at the lbcva says partnering
with n0 allows them to track trade show
customers and how to produce their shows
more efficiently the next year in the
past year with n0 helping to produce the
reports in real time for our trade show
customers 31 of our trade show customers
have taken us up on the invitation lvcva
pays for the program and we do this as
an amenity as customers set up for a
convention and wrap up data reports
through three different Scopes that
traces your direct emissions electricity
you use and what activities you do
meanwhile the lvcva also has their own
programs in place to reduce waste it was
down to cigarette butts being converted
into energy and kitchen grease becoming
biofuel and diverting waste from our
landfills at the tune of 72 percent of
what goes out of this building is being
recycled
now all data reports are available to
every lbcba trade show customer Las
Vegas Convention and visitors
authorities say more than half of their
customers from 2022 are interested in
seeing those reports to plan for future
shows